smack smack stack and in this video
we're be playing black ops 4 that was
just released today on my brand new 492
dollar gaming PC which is built with all
brand new parts we actually tested out
this PC and built it for fortnight you
guys could check out the video by
clicking this card above and I'll also
have a link at the end of this video and
it did really really well in four nights
I'm really excited to see how it
performs with a game that is more
graphics demanding we're gonna go
through a few different settings and
find the best settings for this build
we're also putting together a
step-by-step build guide to show you
exactly how you can build this exact PC
if even if you've never put together
computer before it's gonna make it
extremely easy so make sure you guys are
subscribed you guys have those
notifications enabled so you don't miss
out on that video and along with that I
have the full parts list to this build
in the description below along with some
alternatives if you have a little bit
more money and some extra peripherals
and accessories that I recommend so
let's get right into the game I have my
choice of a dead outfit here there's a
lot of really cool characters I'm gonna
select recon since I like sniping
as you guys could see I just got it
installed and let's go free-for-all find
match I'm not going to touch the
settings at all and we'll see how it
does now I want to confess that I
haven't played a Call of Duty game in a
while now I am a huge FPS shooter fan
and I play a lot of the previous Call of
Duty games but when infinite warfare
came out I kind of skipped on that like
a lot of you guys did and I just went
straight for battlefield one I skipped
the World War two but I'm very excited
to get back into a black ops game I'm
interested to see what it's preset at
what settings but I'm seeing some screen
tearing meaning that we're running above
60 fps and it is ultra smooth
got me so please don't make too much fun
of me in the comment section I like you
guys I just got the game oh do I not
have grenades no your aids so just
starting out I don't have a FPS counter
on right now
I'm impressed this is ultra smooth the
FPS is higher than it needs to be I'm
getting the screen tearing and this
system is under 500 bucks so let's go
into the settings here and see what
we're at display resolution of 4k render
is on half so 1080p
there's our graphics card and I want to
say that nothing is overclocked this is
just basic here texture quality on high
effects on medium model quality high
static reflection quality high okay you
know what that is impressive
dynamic shadows are all shadow quality
on medium weapon shadows on well I'm
actually really impressed at these
settings I thought they would be on low
but no we're on high and medium with
effects on 1080p rendering on a 4k
display and we're getting screen tearing
so we're above 60fps and with no kind of
slowdowns or glitches or drop frames so
let's drop the resolution to 1080p go to
a hundred percent on the render
resolution so I have my FPS counter on
and changing it to 1080p at 100%
resolution actually makes it the game
look better than 4k at 50% come on come
on come on come on come on I gotcha
still have a little bit of skill after
all these years and right after I say
that I'm gonna get killed
now at least it wasn't that guy so frame
rates are above 70 right now come on
come on come on should I aim down the
site above 60 drop down like 64 I think
there I honestly am impressed there we
go
kids get some slide they started off
well but not anymore yeah come on come
on come on come on come on I would have
had him that guy didn't come up behind
me keep in mind I haven't played call of
duty for a couple years now and I'm
finding myself hitting the cue button to
tag people for my teammates
lay down disease the or game I've been
hitting X but it just heals me
so I didn't think I was gonna say this
but let's go in and change our graphics
and boost some things up here I figured
would have to lower graphics but how
about let's go very high on the texture
quality got um hey dude if I get you
graphics seem better
the textures my my weapon looks more
detailed alright guys so I gotta say I
am very impressed with how this system
is working with black ops 4 I expected a
lot worse performance for an entry level
system that cost under $500
so here still above 60s running around
but that was the first time I kind of
noticed a little bit of dropped frames
that's when we switched our textures to
high or the highest option that there
was so that wasn't bad there actually
saw I was dropped on a like 59 let me
okay what is this thing what is this
what is this I don't know what that
thing was I know what button I hit Oh
painful I'm gonna turn the motion blur
off right so it's definitely much better
it's nice and smooth right now okay get
down and get down and get down a heel
heel
dang this is a killer come on man come
on come on come on Oh somebody else took
them dude that is the spot all right so
let's try out one more map and see how
their settings do here it looks like the
default settings did a fantastic job and
you can turn it up to the highest
texture quality but it kind of depends
on the map that last one with all the
snow and effects was a little bit
tougher I had to turn it down
back to the high textures and so that
seems to be good as far as I definitely
need some more practice come on please
let me give up yes I killed somebody
[Applause]
okay okay
kill streak come on
ow
so this is definitely playable for a PC
like this so this is definitely playable
at under $500 I would say that if you do
have a little bit more money to spend
you should pick up that alternate
graphics card that have linked in the
description that will just allow you to
may basically kick the graphics pretty
much all the way to the highest at 1080p
and not have to worry about it but with
that said if you are in a budget and you
have 500 bucks to build a PC you're
definitely gonna be able to play black
ops 4 or even with you know a mix of
medium to high and very high settings
with some of the effects turned on so
honestly I'm quite surprised and very
pleased with this build alright guys so
hopefully you enjoyed watching my very
first few rounds of black ops 4 I
haven't played black ops in a long while
so it feels great to get back into a
game everything just so fast-paced
especially free for all and just being
in the action all the time so as far as
frame rates this thing can definitely
handle playing above 60fps at a mix of
kind of medium to high settings and with
a couple of the different effects turned
on and even textures set all the way up
kind of depending on the map that you're
in without any overclocking or anything
else so like I mentioned we're almost
done editing a step-by-step easy build
guide to show you exactly how to put
together this computer even if you've
never built a PC before and of course
you can upgrade the graphics card if
they have a little bit of a higher
budget but overall I'm very impressed in
the system and not super impressed with
my black ops skills but I will be
getting better at that so make sure you
guys are subscribed you guys have those
notifications enable to you guys don't
miss out on that video and a lot of
other future videos as well that's been
max for max tech and I'll see you in the
next video